teile von kroatien sind jetzt ein
risikogebiet es gibt eine reisewarnung
des auswärtigen amts das bedeutet jeder
der aus dem urlaub zurückkommt muss
einen corona pflicht test machen und
darf erst aus der häuslichen quarantäne
wenn ein negatives testergebnis bekommen
hat wir wollen jetzt mit urlaub man
darüber sprechen was das jetzt für ihren
aktuellen urlaub bedeutet also das ist
mir zugeschaltet alexander bosch ist
gerade auch in kroatien und gleichzeitig
auch noch thomas wer auch im urlaub
die erste frage wie haben sie diese
nachricht aufgenommen
ja was schockierend aber ich denke mal
sagt von vornherein klar dass kroatien
früher oder später zum risikogebiet wird
aber wie gesagt und frage der zeit
ändert das jetzt irgendwas an ihren
urlaubsplänen wir sind jetzt noch genau
bis sonntag hier und ja eigentlich nicht
nur wir haben uns jetzt heute ein boot
gemietet sind auf denen silva und bild
aus und wir genießen unsere global inc
wie ist ein urlaub in einem risikogebiet
merkt man irgendeinen unterschied es
trotzdem genau gleich viel los wie muss
man sich das gerade vorstellen also im
gegenwärtig ist nur im letzten jahr war
halt schon weniger los man hat schon
gemerkt dass ja weniger los ist und dann
auf einmal war ich weg
hallo sehen sie nach ok
wie gesagt am sonntag wurde hier ein
bisschen härtere maßnahmen
durchgegriffen spricht dass die ganzen
cafés bis 12 uhr geschlossen werden und
das hat man auch in der reva wird
gemerkt dass halt ja weniger leute da
sind super mal wird weiterhin mit maske
und alles aber da kümmert sich jetzt
auch keiner wenn man keine ahnung
das klingt nicht ganz nach den
schutzmaßnahmen
vielen dank für diese einblicke ich
natürlich noch einen schönen urlaub bis
sonntag dann danke schön
ja wir wollen auch mit thomas der
sprechen auch im urlaub momentan sagen
sie mir kurz erst mal wo genau sie
gerade sind
gerade im bremer auch ein böser blick
und wie haben sie die nachricht
aufgenommen
dieser reisewarnung auch jetzt den test
die pflicht fest sie jetzt machen müssen
wenn sie dann zurück nach deutschland
kommen gute story zu erwarten nachdem
die österreicher erster schritt gemacht
es sind ziemlich alle genervt weil wir
wissen nicht was jetzt auf uns zukommt
wir fahren nach hause werden getestet
muss unter häuslicher quarantäne gehen
es ist halt alles von den großen
fragezeichen verbunden natürlich hat sie
diese nachricht erst erreicht als ich
schon im urlaub waren würden sie jetzt
trotzdem noch einmal fahren jetzt wo das
ein risikogebiet es eine reisewarnung
gibt ja ich fühle mich gegend lich
sichere wie in deutschland
die strände sind relativ leer
ich habe jetzt keinen vergleich zum
vorjahr aber ich nenne da war es wird
alles abstände gehalten hygienemaßnahmen
und ich war bei uns zu hause in nürnberg
am altmühlsee da war es wesentlich für
das zufall
dann wünsche ich natürlich auch ihnen
noch einen schönen urlaub und wir hoffen
natürlich auf negative testergebnisse
dann vielen dank dankeschön
ja und über die tests möchte ich jetzt
aussprechen mit meinem kollegen hannes
kohlmaier
er ist nämlich an einem der testzentren
in der nähe von passau also dort wo es
jetzt auch vor kurzem noch die großen
test pannen in bayern gab hannes hug uns
ist das alles mittlerweile etwas besser
und vielleicht anders koordiniert ich
habe das gefühl dass die behörden dazu
gelernt haben findet ihr alles etwas
professioneller stadt sei es aber muss
ja nicht mit bleistiften wir die
zettelchen ausfüllen kann man wenn man
kein handy hat aber die bessere methode
tatsächlich einen den weg die daten erst
online einzugeben
danach bekommt man einen qr code mit dem
bekommt man es teststäbchen und der test
ist innerhalb von fünf minuten dann
passiert allerdings die wartezeiten
die sind vielleicht jetzt mittlerweile
ein bisschen ein problem heute morgen um
halb acht war schon schlangen da aber
man sieht sie trainiert geschlagen
werden jetzt immer größer das sind
diejenigen reiserückkehrer die heute in
der nacht losgefahren sind die ganze
nacht durchgefahren sind und natürlich
jetzt in der sengenden sonne stehen das
ist nicht schön wie lang sind die
wartezeiten jetzt gerade ungefähr bei
der also ich rechne so mit ungefähr 15
bis 20 minuten
dazu kommt noch die parkplatzsuche der
parkplatz hier ist nämlich etwas
überfüllt die polizei macht das ganz
prima die koordiniert ein bisschen die
anfahrenden fahrzeuge
allerdings stehen auch zum glück hat der
der autobahn rastplatz zugang zu einem
feldweg also nach draußen und der ist
rappelvoll mit fahrzeugen muss sich auch
selber testen lassen wir haben bilder
davon vielleicht kannst du noch einmal
kurz beschreiben wie der test
funktioniert und vor allem jetzt an
einer raststätte worauf man achten muss
die besonders positive überraschung war
dass niemand mir ein test steht geht in
die nase eingeführt hat das hab ich
schon zwei mal gemacht das war relativ
unangenehm als es kommt hier ein
rachenabstrich der da spürt man also
nichts im gegensatz zu diesen
nasenabstrich der politik wehtut aber
sehr unangenehm ist und das testergebnis
sollen wir innerhalb von zwei bis drei
tagen dann erfahren